[Musique]
voilà juste ici qu'on va pouvoir
tous les composés tous les
quand on arrive on analyse on a juste
une poudre blanche et en fait on
découvre plein de produits à l'intérieur
donc c'est hyper intéressant des fois on
travaille
dans le et là on est dans le cadre d'une
garde à vue donc il faut rendre les
résultats dans la journée on aide
vraiment les forces de police dans leur
métier c'est on se sent utile
[Musique]
donc en fait
le type de rayonnement on mettra en
œuvre tous les moyens du laboratoire
pour la sécurité des JO bien sûr et
on va avoir des moyens de répondre
dès qu'il y aura un incident
et permettre d'identifier rapidement
si on est face à une menace ou pas
[Musique]
le sujet c'est simplement d'être
toujours aussi performant pour pouvoir
traiter un maximum d'analyses si on est
appelé sur différents sites olympiques
ou d'autres choses qu'on soit capable de
réagir rapidement et de façon efficace